hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
freddy's this is going to be the final
episode because i am going to get to the
bottom of this mystery and explore what
is really going on in the pizza
plex also i got robbed i got robbed
during my stream chica popped up out of
nowhere and it sent me back here but now
i'm not gonna fool around i'm not gonna
waste time because i know exactly what i
need to do
mostly and i know exactly where i need
to go so i'm going to start
by going to get the thing that i thought
was
by killing monty so i'm going to go kill
monty i'll be back in a bit later once i
actually know what i need to do but
right now i just need to play get to
where i was before so that i can show
you everything that you need to know if
you wanted to know all the secrets of
five nights at freddy's
this is where it is
or maybe maybe not i have no idea
i'm just being dramatic okay status
update i saw golden freddy i saw the
puppet i saw it all the marionette baby
was here it was nuts but my recording
failed it was so cool i wish i could
have shown you i just wanted you to know
that i saw them definitely
funny they were all playing in the ball
pit in monty's golf but i just forgot to
record it
anyway i'm going to continue up to mesa
size i'll be right back okay actually i
am back because one of the things that i
got to do i don't know exactly why but i
know what it's going to affect is i have
to take pictures of all these characters
that are on this movie poster that's in
the daycare theater watch what happens
pretty weird huh
kinda strange also i forgot to get this
not these collectibles super matter and
if you haven't seen my uh
warning tampering with fazbear automated
watch yourself if you haven't seen my uh
my stream yet
i st i
before i actually did the upgrade of
freddy
i did a few more things and i got a few
more items
which allows me to be a little quicker
in this before i committed to 6am and i
can't save anymore so everything you see
from now on i cannot save
also this
okay
that's a clear path
douchebag
okay waba
booey okay
got that now i just need to upgrade
freddy because there are some things
that i need to show you that are behind
clawed fences well they will be clawed
once i'm done with them i'm also gonna
utilize no no not the bucket
i'm gonna utilize freddie a bit more
because that's something that i have not
been doing
not nearly enough anyway
i'm just gonna walk right out
hello
don't mind me just freddie enjoying a
bit of golf
i love golf
it's my favorite activity
i'm freddy
i'm mr five nights
don't mind me
five nights at fred me coming through
all right goodbye
so now i'm gonna show you what comes
next right now okay we made it through
the claw upgrade with no problem i knew
it was gonna be fine okay so we have
this upgrade all solid we're good to go
we have the claws so the next step is
i'm gonna try to find more of those
cardboard cutouts the one that i showed
you the mermaid chica that i flashed and
then the eyes lit up
it's not a typical reaction to flashing
but in this case it's gonna help me do
something
something really funky now here's
another one of them this thing oh it's a
safe spot this thing
[Music]
strange yes strange very strange it'll
all make sense very soon
but also we're gonna go down into the
basement so one of the things that i
found was this message that says
security report 12 24 am bonnie is
seeing leaving his green room and rock
star row heading east towards the atrium
2 40 a.m bonnie enters the east arcade
for 12 a.m bonnie enters monty golf
so something about bonnie
is key to all of the things that are
happening in this
adventure i hesitate to call it an
adventure
uh more like a calamity or a disaster
but
something has to do with
bonnie and bonnie's
either disappearance or decommissioning
there's something
something strange
and there's also something strange with
this room here that you can get into
which just has a static screen from a
projector and a particular item that you
can get in this room is
the sun figure
go figure
but the most important
uh weird secret in this place
is yet to come
why can't i hear that music
not this this is amazing the fox plush
is really great and all but that's not
the main secret
the main secret
is over here
it's right here behind two gates one
that you can only get through if you
have the claw upgrade and the other you
need chica zoo
chica's shouting ability to get through
so you need to basically have an
upgraded freddy
thank you
thank you very much
thank you very much
and it's that sound
you know what that sound is
it's a sound of progress
i forgot
sorry freddie
i just needed to i apologize
so yeah this may look familiar
if you've played sister location or seen
my video on sister location and those
are the exotic butlers
and that's tv if you've never seen tv
but there's also this on the wall it
says it requires item i don't know what
item i have several items in my
inventory including this weird
performance disc and
other stuff what is this
great
great stuff
yeah so i've got a lot of random crap
i don't know why i have a lot of random
crap
but
you know
something needs to go in here that looks
like a physical magnetic tape
and i'm betting that it'll play a
message if i do get it so that's kind of
part of what i'm looking for and we're
starting to reach the limit of what i've
seen
what i was doing in my stream but i have
a lead on where to go from here because
there still are a few more things
a few more little secret surprises
here and there and everywhere i call
this the freddy assist
so i can't make it through this gap but
he can
and i just hop in him and then he spits
me back out and i'm through the gap that
i couldn't get through i'm sure that
could be used to speed run or break the
game in several different ways
but for this it helped me get through a
gap that for some reason i couldn't get
through before
just that easy and then boom i'm here in
the atrium
which is
where i wanted to be definitely 100
100
100
100
100
so there's one more place i need to go
before i go to the daycare and honestly
i probably should have gone there first
because now i have to kind of circle
back around
but i'll be back when i'm there
warning tampering with fazbear automated
shots
god damn that was a good shot
god damn that was a good shot okay the
reason i'm going well
i gotta get through this zone
which is easy if i just take my time
i understand exactly where i'm going
because one of the main problems is that
chica whoa
uh let me get in i'm just gonna use
freddy you know i'm just gonna use
freddy because freddy's here and i've
been burned before in this exact moment
because i was too silly to use freddy
and i'm not gonna be that silly anymore
because freddie's here freddie makes it
perfectly easy and just getting through
this section alone is all i really need
that's it that's all there is that's all
there is to it i'm not gonna die again
i'm not i'm not gonna die again i just
refuse to i absolutely refuse to okay so
i'm back here
and for those of you who are curious of
those of you who haven't seen this
stream i need to be back here because
there's something at the end of this
hallway there's actually two somethings
at the end of this hallway
the first of which is princess quest 2
which is an arcade game that i played
both all well all three of on the
stream so if you want to see the
quote-unquote good ending
go check that out this is something else
i needed that
and i should have gotten that before but
i didn't have the camera at the time so
now i have to go all the way what the
hell
what
what the hell
why is that glowing
why is that glowing
what
what
why is that glowing
what
why is that glowing
what the hell
it's like sizzling
what
i've never seen that before in my life i
have no idea what that's about
that's weird
okay
not my problem
okay
but for now i'm just gonna get in freddy
again and we're gonna go right through
this section one more time easy peasy
maybe i'll even take him to the dance
floor if he's a good boy
are you a good boy freddy are you a good
boy you good boy freddy you're gonna be
good you're gonna be good to me
you better be good to me i wonder if i
uh wonder if i got out of him over the
ledge there if he would just dump me
onto the floor
worth a try but not right now ah it's
fine
okay because i can just do this
yo
whoa hey bud
okay i'm kind of curious about something
if i hop in him and i go on this dance
floor with me inside him
i hope i hope it don't crush me this is
gonna crush me to death no god i really
wanted him to do something with
uh dj music man over there i really
thought that there was gonna be like
some freddy dancing but
alas we do not deserve it we are not
good enough
that is so in your eyes
[Music]
oh okay
crazy
getting out of your mind
fine
all right i'll be back so what i need to
do now is i need to go into the theater
go past the theater and then go
downstairs
into the basement of the theater because
you're gonna notice something in this
poster that i'm about to go past
you'll notice that there are some
glowing eyes
equivalent to the characters that i
personally flashed and there's one more
foxy
who we also have not seen and has been
replaced by roxy
very peculiar
hmm yeah you following me you following
me this threat of mystery goes deep
but i'll get to the bottom of it you
better be deactivated
you better be deactivated
you all better stay deactivated
he's right here
bam
bada
oh
bing
do not like that i do not like it
all right so now
we hop back in old fred boy here
and we make our way to that poster and
then we do something with it
i don't know what but we do something
oh
interesting
very interesting
ah
uh-huh
oh
oh
oh well this is something
oh
oh my goodness
that's balloon world
hey
would you look at that
it's balloon boy world
and another golden box
golden moon
i didn't get the one from
golf
tournament paper it is there but you can
see i already got that one they're
working together the arcades they're
hiding something the glitches glitch
them all at the same time then the
princess will recognize me she's testing
me i'm not yet worthy the others are
protecting it let me stay i am so close
just one more night please i can save
the princess
glitch them what do you mean oh i can
play this one
oh
oh
see i couldn't play chica's feeding
frenzy
oh weird
how do i play
oh what
oh weird
[Music]
oh what the hell
[Music]
oh this is uh
kind of cool
ah damn it
[Music]
i don't know how important it is to get
those
[Music]
i don't know how important it is to get
that or maybe that was an obstacle i
don't know
how would i get that
[Music]
oh god
oh that's
unsettling
[Music]
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh
all right hold on
oh good glitch them i have to glitch
this
i have to figure out how to make this
not work
that's the question
or that's the thing what am i supposed
to do am i supposed to get like some
kind of a score am i supposed to break
9000
wait is the screen flashing
[Music]
is it starting to break
[Music]
oh god no
it's like that helicopter game
[Music]
okay
oh oh i'm seeing glitches
[Music]
i saw that that was a glitch
that was most certainly a glitch
i saw a glitch there for a little bit
what did i need to do
[Music]
did i need to do something with that
little glitch there or
was there something else
that was a painful night cycle
oh god no
oh no
no there's something else there what is
that
oh definitely not don't touch it okay
well i just i think i just ruined my
chances because i was like oh maybe i
touch it
but no
of course not
what do i do i saw the little glitch but
what does that mean
oh it's being so nice
[Music]
what
oh my god
the game just crashed
well i got the game to glitch
i sure did didn't i
i definitely got the game to glitch
i'll be back
gregory you have a choice to make
okay
i just got the claws i've killed monty
i'm gonna do a thing
that i've been dreaming
about where did you get these parts i'd
rather but i'm not a hundred percent
sure if it's gonna work i should now be
able to smash through the cycling fences
around the building the way monty does
exactly like he did
yeah exactly like he did
so i'm gonna do a thing
i'm gonna do a thing here
i'm gonna get to a thing eventually i'm
gonna get to a thing but for now i'm
gonna do a thing
and it's fine
but i'm gonna check to see if there's a
way that i can actually save maybe
maybe
i don't know
for sure
but maybe there's a way that i could
save my game and if that's true then
that means i could save myself a whole
hell of a lot of headache if there ever
is a game crash
especially when i'm trying to glitch the
game inside the game but the game inside
the game causes my game that it's inside
of to crash
which is very bad you know i'm fine if
my skill is bad and i
fail somehow i just need to go uh while
i'm here i'm gonna go get this uh
cut out here but i'm fine if like i mess
up
but if the game just crashes there's
nothing i can do about that so i'm gonna
try to do whatever i can to save in case
that happens again
wham
all right i'll be back so from what i've
been told
there's a way to get an auto save to
occur
if you go into roxy's raceway i don't
remember what specifically
caused it to occur
but this is what i heard and at this
point i will do anything
so if this can get an autosave to happen
i will take it
because i can't deal with another crash
or losing or starting over again
i can't deal
i won't deal i refuse to deal oh god
you're here
oh god you're here you're here no no no
no not like this
oh my god
oh my god if you kill me i swear if you
kill me
okay
duly noted you're still here
i should be in freddy
why am i not just in freddy
i forgot that freddy is a thing i always
forget why do i forget cause i'm dumb
i think it's just that simple i might be
dumb
i might be a big old dumbass i think i
think they said something about this
oh
good job you have found a driver
assistant
i do not believe it will work in that
condition though however there is a
staff repair station in the west arcade
you will need a dance pass to access the
west arcade have you checked the party
garages
the raceway was closed very abruptly
prior to the new construction
guests tend to leave things behind
during emergency situations
it just went to 5 15.
the clock literally
went to 5 15. i don't know if this is
going to permanently break the game
which it seems very likely to do
so
if it's 5 15 that must mean that a save
is
save is available
right wow you were hanging out right
there aren't you
you are right there ah you stay right
there freddy you stay right there
you stay right there
okay i'm just gonna create a new slot
i am
still wow
okay all right okay okay okay enough of
that enough of you
all right
that has probably permanently broken the
game i would imagine because that seems
like something that you shouldn't be
able to do
and yet here we are
okay
i have a save
yeah that didn't just start an auto save
that
that did everything
that gave me a new lease on life
that's what that gave me okay i gotta
what are you doing
that's what i thought that's what i
thought and that's what i thought that's
what i thought that's so that's what i
thought
that's what i thought okay so i gotta
get up to the
i get to get up to the
arcade not for the reason that it's
saying that i should get up there but
for the reason that i'm saying i should
get up there
which is a different reason and i
haven't even told you what the reason is
but i need to get up there
so shush
shush you and shush me all right let us
away freddy all right i'll be back once
i get some stuff done
now that i have a save in my pocket
and hopefully more saves in the future
this might be the start of something
beautiful everybody this might be the
start of something beautiful god can you
imagine saves can you imagine saves can
you imagine saves i'm just doing new
slots every time i don't know why but
can you imagine saving your game
oh i can imagine i can imagine i can
imagine it now i can imagine it
i can imagine it now
i can imagine it now
i can hardly believe it but i'm about to
go get the last cut out again
and i have saves
so many saves
so many delightful saves
oh my god
oh
good thing i have a save
what the hell
oh my god
what was that
okay don't touch those things apparently
nobody likes that oh see that's another
thing that i'm glad i have a save right
here
right outside the daycare hmm that's
peculiar
let me slide into fun
i guess i can't do that oh well whatever
okay now i'm gonna do that again but be
a little more cautious this time and a
little more suspecting that these things
are actually still alive and i should
not touch them
i should not touch them at all
keep a good distance from them
at all times
hey
yay
[Music]
yeah those sounds that's not good sound
oh
why
why do you do those sounds
i don't like those sounds
bad sounds
bad bad sounds
all right good
great i think i know how to glitch it
i need to get to those little glitch
things and then i need to die at that
point
it sounds strange but i think that's
what it is because when balloon boy dies
he goes all the way up and all the way
down which probably means that if he
dies at that moment
it would
cause him to go up into that glitch
because it didn't see i don't think it's
a thing where you got to play it a
million times
to get the ultimate high score i don't
think that matters
i think it's about
those little squiggles and making them
work for you
right
so i just got to get to the cave because
that's where i saw the first one if it's
in the same place it might be it might
not be
there
whoa
that's what i'm talking about
that's what it is
that's the thing
what was that
[Music]
so i needed i that i was right but i
didn't have to die
all i had to do was physically touch it
where's the next one i know it was
around here
there it is
there
oh
[Music]
i think that's what you might call a
glitch
[Music]
oh yeah
oh wow
i don't know if i'm supposed to follow
this path or what
[Music]
oh wow
oh wow
oh god
no oh it was right there
now
i don't know why i went for the balloon
but it just seemed like the right thing
to do
i know i was supposed to trace the path
but god damn it
god damn it hang on let me check what
that achievement was because if it says
maintenance log balloon world out of
order
did i do it
did i did i actually do it
did i glitch it
i think i did
does that mean i
does that mean it's good i got the
achievement so that must mean that it's
good right
i'm done with that
right that's what that means
i i glitched it as much as i could
possibly glitch it
right
it must be i i must have done it okay
i must have i must have done that i must
have
i must have done that
i must i must have
i did it and that's all there is to it
i'm really hoping that it actually
worked because i i don't know it just
gave me an achievement and i have a
vague note that says glitch them all
okay ties and glitch them all at the
same time then the princess will
recognize me she's testing me i am not
yet worthy the others are protecting it
let me say i'm so close
they're working together
they're hiding something i don't know
what you're talking about
i don't know
is it talking about the princess one to
glitch it because i guess
i guess technically that's what i
no
no
i do not know
i don't know all right
there's something else that i want to do
i know that there's something that you
need for that room downstairs
clearly you need some kind of an item
there
and i don't know what that is yet
i don't know what it is yet
but i will get to it
i will get to it in just a hot second
because there's one other thing that i
want to try
here
wasn't there
i believe over in the photo area
uh
something like this something about this
something about this over here in this
side
i believe there was a fence that freddie
can now bash through it was either this
side or the main race area but i've kind
of combed through that and i i didn't
see it over there so i'm thinking that
it's over here
uh maybe i can see it on this map
the map
the map the map the map the map
i'm at the map looking at the map
up top wasn't it up top here
up top here
up top up tip at the top here
wasn't there something up here
eh
no i guess not
maybe not here maybe it was in the other
area let me just comb through this real
quick
really carefully
looking through all of this stuff wasn't
there something
am i crazy this is where princess quest
was the first one i already did that i
did all of that so i don't need to do
that again oh hello
shoes
shoes am i faster
why didn't i get that sooner
oh why didn't i get am i i'm definitely
faster i'm so much faster i'm definitely
faster
oh i'm fast
oh no way
no way there are so many of these guys
around here all right what about over
here
is there anything over here okay it must
have been in the other section i know
there's a fence here
i know there is i remember there being
one oh
ah there was this one i don't know
what's the point of this
oh i guess so either that one was for
chica to get through and that was for
monty
so i guess it could have been either or
yeah
that's not really what i'm looking for
there's this
whoa
right
right where the people went down to
investigate the thing the power draw
it was here
whoa
hey pal
good to see you again thanks what is
this
oh
what is this
oh hello
what's all this then
what's all this then
where am i
huh not on the map
i've gone off the grid
okay
now we're getting somewhere
convenient
chica thing thank you
oh hello
gregory be careful
this elevator does not appear to follow
any safety protocols
i do not think it can survive more than
one trip
well get your ass in here fred boy
are you telling me that i could have
just gone down here am i sure for what
that i didn't have to do any of that
[ __ ]
hey buddy calm yourself down there
freddy
i'm not doing that
i didn't edit that audio
i edited the other audio it's doing what
i was doing
what are you oh
oh
come along freddy
you're a good boy freddy
what
what
i'm sorry
i'm sorry
what is that
what is that freddy what is that
ready
what uh
what is any of this
okay
all right i'm not touching those things
ready
whoa
freddy good boy good boy freddy good oh
hi what are you doing here freddy
what
can you just not
come along freddy don't worry about it
don't worry about it
it's all good what
what
oh
[Music]
okay
okay
this is just here
oh
i see
okay
freddie do you have anything to say
about this or was i supposed to be in
you this whole time ham let me back up a
couple steps here
you have anything to say about this no
nothing at all
strange huh
very weird i don't think i was supposed
to because i had to turn on all these
generators anyway
that's probably fine nothing to say
about this a friendster
nothing to say at all weird huh
this doesn't uh seem familiar to you
you're not uh and no memories coming up
out of the ether
no it's just a pizzeria that's under the
ground here
perfectly normal
very very
normal
whoa what the hell is that
what the hell
is that about
i can just go down there okay
that's normal
that's normal
that is normal
this is very normal
wow
all right
come on boy
no time like the present let's get down
here
you i know what this is
i have been here
before she brought me here
i found myself for the first time when i
cleared the path
i did not want to
but i had no choice
now i have a choice
i have changed
my friends are here
they are so angry
confused
but i can protect you i
am not
me
you are not you
hmm
well that's a different tune from the
it's me
that's what you meant by you can protect
me i uh
[Music]
i see
all right
okay all right
well let's try that again
red boy you guys stay close this time uh
i'll be right back guys okay i know what
this is
i have been here before
she brought me here uh-huh
i found myself for the first time when i
cleared the path
i did not want to
but i had no
choice now i have a choice what the hell
i have changed
my friends are here oh they are so angry
but i can confused
you
i
am not
me
you am not you
[Applause]
okay
what oh uh
freddy you
are you okay
he is trying to take control of me
i just lit it on fire uh
what
what oh
i'm playing fnaf
i'm playing fnaf three
i'm playing for an f3 okay
uh springtrap's here and i'm playing
finale chica shut the doors which one
which
what are you talking about
where
oh
maybe that door oh bye it's not a big
deal
zip zappity boop
okay
oh she still moves
all right well
this is a little odd
huh
this is so bizarre also i noticed there
was an auto save down at the bottom are
you telling me that if i had to just
hippity-hop down here
hide what do you mean hide
hide where
hide where
where where
what
i don't know where to hide so i tucked
behind something
in you wait in in you you you no that
was wrong move
oh well that's not good
i'm hiding
i'm hiding
i'm hiding so good
i did it
oh what why do what
what are you doing what are you doing
what are you doing what are you doing
what are you doing freddy you didn't
tell me that you were all crazy
oh my god
but also there seems to have been an
auto save here so i could have just come
down here instead of doing the whole
exploitative thing
but it's fine it's whatever i don't even
care anymore who are you gonna call
nobody
there's nobody to call okay so story
is don't let freddie get you apparently
it was a good hiding place because even
freddie couldn't find me but whatever
and i don't know if it's important
what was that
aren't you okay
he is trying to take control of me
what happens if i go out
no those doors are closed he
what is that thing
roast maybe i do that when he's taking
control of freddy i roasty toasty and
that'll distract him you know what i
mean that'll probably do it
that's probably the strategy
look out it's chica shut the doors
so i roast yeah that does it okay
yeah no don't do it
all right well that did nothing
hey hello
all right let's see you go
nope
okay that's how you do that
so the problem is when
roxy would be here that would be a bit
of a tough situation
but so far this seems pretty simple what
do i do the doors will not hold her hide
you got it
oh
you don't know i'm here you don't know
you don't know
you don't know you don't know you don't
know you don't know you don't know oh my
god you don't oh my god you don't know
you don't know you don't know you don't
know go away
you don't know you don't know
yeah that's right that's right that's
right you don't know
you don't know
you have no idea
oh my god what is this nonsense
get me in get me in come in let me in
just uh good old
i guess i was supposed to hide in freddy
the whole time
well that's a shame
freddy you betrayed me how could you do
such a thing how could you do that to me
i thought we were friends it's roxy what
do i do
i'm hiding
okay
yeah i sure hope that i don't
well
it happened
the thing i didn't want to happen
happened oh my god are you serious
freddie right now you gotta take a piss
yeah i gotta take a piss now
freddie are you joking me
oh my god please do not
i have no idea what's happening
i win
i
i win
i i win
what is freddy doing in there
no no no why
oh my god
this is such a weird
mess
and there she goes
and here she comes
okay as amusing as this is i'm obviously
not making any progress you tired you
tuckered you tuckered me roxy you
tuckered now
you all tired out
no
that's okay
that's okay
you take a break
you take a little nap
you relax
you take a load off you take a break now
you take a break you earned it oh you're
peppy again all right i don't know what
i'm doing i'm gonna make a break for it
you can't catch me i got shoes
all right come at me come at me yeah you
want some of this
yeah you sure seem like you can see good
for someone who's blind
what
yeah
take some of that
what do you think of that
that's what i thought
can't figure your way out of a door huh
oh does puppy want in oh puppy won't be
[Music]
listen you lost you lost that's just the
way it is
oh so tired
i don't know what's happening i don't
know what's happening
i don't know what's going on
i legitimately have no idea
like why is freddy stuck in that tube
why is this not doing nothing
why is roxy being this way
roxy literally will not let go no matter
what
come on
come at me i'll let you here
i'll let you
all right fine
why nothing has changed at all what do
you mean
oh you're so silly
everything's exactly as it was
anyway time to fight this fight again
all right so what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna prioritize hiding
um just because
i think that
there's probably a way to blind freddy
like when he's possessed unless that's
like too late and uh no good for anybody
but
i think that there's a way
blind
hello
he is trying to fly though what is that
thing
so i'm gonna just i know that i can hide
from roxy
oh maybe here too probably not there i
think behind the bed is the bed
i thought i got stuck i think behind the
bed is probably the best bet
and then whenever i get a chance try to
snap this and if that doesn't work i'll
figure something else out so i just hide
and even if he gets possessed i'm just
gonna wait
yeah because he's being possessed but me
running out for some reason makes roxy
just constantly want to be a part of me
well it's red there
no there she goes
oh here she comes
let's see if roxy okay maybe i'm not
hiding right and it was just a fluke
that when i went behind the bed
i got free well she almost got me there
oh
i think i know what was supposed to
happen i think i know
i think that's why freddie ran into the
tube
because i got in his chest and then he
went to hide
but i just have to make sure that i
don't
uh
let him get possessed before i do that i
gotta like wait for the last minute
which probably means that i do have to
close the door
even though i heard him say the doors
won't hold her
it might hold her just long enough to be
able to get
uh freddy free and then into a pod
i think that's probably the correct
solution
if not then i'm dumb and i don't know so
whatever happens i definitely the only
place to hide in this entire building is
in freddy
so what i'll do
is i'll try to close the door
it's chica shut the doors
which door
how you doing
okay bye
it's roxy what do i do
did you go over where'd you go
okay if i hop in here although
i feel like i was
in here
i don't know
something seems off still doesn't seem
quite right
oh
we'll see that's uh that's the issue
there
right there that's the issue
can i get in there with you
can i hop in
please
room for two
here
oh
this is weird
why would it do that
why are you over there oh why are you
coming over here
no
hide hide
where could i possibly hide here
it's a little strange
awfully strange for a creature that um
can't see
to be able to see me so well
so what do you do
it's
i feel like it's something with freddy
going into those pods but for some
reason he goes in
without me
don't know why but he do
it might i don't know it might have
something to do with the fact that the
game is that i've glitched the game with
that save thing but
i don't know
like i'd be willing to go back and do it
normally because there's an auto save
down here and it wouldn't take that much
effort to just pop on down
but uh
i can't help but feel there's got to be
like something else here
you know
what was that
let me see are you
he is trying to take control of me
i do not think i can fight it for long
he
what is that thing
okay he just spat me out no that's
because i press e
okay so
okay suddenly he's low power
why
i don't know
and now this opens for him it's chica
[Music]
well now i'm stuck in here
what
what
ah
oh
oh okay what
i
i don't know
i oh wow
freddy you're right there pal
so i made it in
oh no oh no we've got he got too much
juice
oh no that's fine
okay why
oh monty that's why
well uh
freddie oh he's back
but i did kind of technically
hide i think
is he there or what's the deal
no he's he's gone
okay
i'm winning
i'm winning
i'm win
what do i do
okay
whatever but okay i'm trying to you
gonna do nope okay here we go
i'm gonna try this thing again
okay i'm in here now
well that's oh you are so unfortunate
and he's spinning again
great i don't know i don't understand
this is so strange i'm just not sure
what the deal is
when roxy comes out everything just for
some reason breaks
whoa
easy there girl i mean it probably has
to do with the idea that
whoa hey whoa okay all right well freddy
got out i guess and that means that i i
guess i could
pop back in or something i don't know if
if it does if i can't get it to work
this time i think it definitely is super
bugged
and it's probably due to the fact that
it's not 6am or something like that
you know what i mean
so i might have to go back and do it
again which is
oh i forgot i'm not in freddy
i'm not me
right
you know actually it's worth a shot
i think there will be an auto save
because there was an auto save here
and why else would there be an auto save
if not for that purpose
so
i think what i need to do is i need to
go back
and i need to do
it
the correct way so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to go back i'm going to get
monty i'm going to upgrade the whole
thing and then i'm going to go straight
to roxy you have a troll you are staying
hi i'm cuz
why not
this part all right i'll be back
okay
so i have the claws all i need to do is
install them
and then go to roxy's raceway not do the
autosave thing but just go down the
stairs
into the pit
and theoretically
that's it
right
unless i'm not paying attention to
something important and it's gonna come
back and bite me in the ass quite
literally probably roxy
you miss this one
whoa
why are you here
this is not worth it
it's so not worth it
not worth it
why am i doing it i don't know not worth
it
oh
a freddy upgrade
what does that mean
what does that mean
freddie just get your ass over here
freddy just get your ass over here oh
come on
come on freddy
we gotta go
we gotta go
cause we can't die
oh i got a new bar battery
that would have been useful literally
forever ago
but okay here we go i'm hoping there's
an autosave and the benefit is i think
if it's still broken i just go back to
my old save
which should still exist
but now we have freddy
um not ua
you am not you
well i am me and me i'm markiplier and
me i'm finally gonna beat this no matter
what what was that
okay okay i'm hoping that this works now
well those still aren't enterable but
i'm not gonna discount that
not gonna discount anything what is that
thing
all right
here we go
so
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna close
that
get in him
see if i can get over to one of these
things over here
it doesn't open okay well that's
different at least
uh
don't mind me oh there it goes
oh boy okay well that's a problem he's
gotta go potty
oh no
it's still just as broken isn't it it's
still broken
how
this makes no sense
let me go rescue my whoa
why was he rocketing towards me um can i
hop in you wait oh my god wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait come here come here
come here come here come here
oh my god it's not letting me in why is
it not letting me in
oh is this let me in
i'm hidden you can't get me
okay well that's just patently unfair
why would you do that
what
i'm at a loss
i'm so confused
i didn't even do the save bug or
anything like that
she's just here
why
i have no idea
i cannot see
good good good great good great
he's still coming after me even though
he's being possessed
i don't know why i'm even bothering with
this but whatever
oh low power well if only there was a
way to fix that huh
if only there was a way to fix that and
i'm where am i going i don't know what
he's now
just moving
and he's he's stuck
i i don't know
well
this is unfortunate for me
yep and now i'm out okay where am i uh
oh
i win
[Music]
oh
look at that
[Music]
that's pretty nice
very peaceful
okay so i think i've done it i got the
three star ending the good ending and i
got the two star ending that ending
there's only one other ending left to
play
let me see oh it did do an auto save oh
that would have been very nice of it i
appreciate that there's actually only
one other ending left to do in this
entire game and i think it's fitting
that this is the last one i do i think
you know what i'm gonna prefer to
no not the van ending i didn't know the
last one
the door is the only choice to really
make can go
or you can continue to investigate the
secrets of the pizza plex i feel there
is something else going on besides fanny
yeah besides vani all right you have
good luck with that
all right bye
later
manny the kid's sleeping in a box whoa
jeez are you gonna no okay okay okay
so
that is the end of five nights at
freddy's security breach as far as i
know
i still don't know what the deal was
with those arcade games the fact that
balloon boy could glitch and there was
the golf game i couldn't figure out what
the glitch was there but there's
something there maybe i don't know if
it's like
a factor in it but i feel like there's
some other thing with all of these weird
accessory collectibles and whatnot
there's something else there why was
that arcade cabinet so hard to get to
right
why
there must have been a reason and there
must have been a reason for glitching it
out like you did that got you an
achievement which was
interesting
why did that happen but it's a mystery
for another day
i'm uh
pretty satisfied with my experience in
this game obviously it was lacking
polish
and
i i don't want to say it was missing
like quality testing because i'm sure
there was quality testing but clearly
there's an extraordinary amount of bugs
in this game
but i still got through it and it still
was
in the universe of five nights at
freddy's and that's what i caught most
of the time
um when i look past the bugs and whatnot
what you get is a glimpse into a
universe that is really interesting and
intriguing and that's what five nights
at freddy's is all about it's a universe
that you want to know more of because
it's so horrifying
not horrifying like it's the scariest
thing in the world horrifying as if the
idea behind the actual truth of the
animatronics is literally horrifying
and you caught some of that i think they
could have done a little more
because it was so much that was hidden
away and it was so much reliant on the
jump scares and stuff but something
about the
the kind of distortion of freddy once
you got that voice box in them stopped
right as soon as i got the voice box in
him he delivered those few lines that
were super creepy and i saw him going
down a path of being like oh am i
corrupting freddy by putting all these
other parts in him and then that was
just kind of lost and i was like hmm
i feel like there could have been
something more with that darkness to it
that corruption of it the kind of
collection of all these other parts from
the other animatronics and putting it
into freddy but somehow that's not good
so
either way
it was fun thank you everybody so much
for watching if there is some big deep
dark secret in this
let me know down in the comments below
thank you everybody so much for watching
uh links to all the five nights at
freddy's games i've ever played in the
description there i've got a big
playlist also fan games are there uh
thank you so much for joining me on this
journey i have a podcast i would love
for you to check it out but it's up to
you link is also down there in the
description thank you
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]